[музика]
вітаємо Ласкаво просимо до програми У
фокусі Європа раді що ви з нами Вінні в
Україні не видно кінця минув майже рік
від її початку
І як наприклад у бахмуті Східна частина
країни постійно піддається атакам
російських військ оскільки війна триває
Пропаганда стає все більш важливою для
Путіна
тому що російський президент веде війну
зброю й словом і це дуже непокоїть
сусідню Латвію
у прикордонному місці ризик не проживає
багато етнічних росіян які часто мають
тісні зв'язки з Росією латвійка Марія
дубіцька вважає що багато з них
піддаються впливу путінської пропаганди
Вона боїться що це може розколоти
Латвійське суспільство
[музика]
наших сувені дітей
уздовж латвійсько-російського кордону у
багатьох латвійців тут ловить через
супутник та інтернет російське державне
телебачення А разом з ним і путінську
пропаганду
[музика]
это будет ядерная война
погрози війни доносяться через кордон
від Росії це турбує Марії дубіцько як і
вона кожен четвертий латвієць має
російське походження і розмовляє
російською війна в Україні дедалі більше
поляризує Латвію від самого її початку
ми втрачаємо своїх сусідів ми втрачаємо
своїх друзів це дуже боляче Пропаганда
вона як отрута псує наші взаємини тут
66-річна Марія та її син Яніс мають
багато російських друзів і знайомих
російські ЗМІ в Латвії заблоковані але
російськомовні люди знайшли способи
вмикати їх а після вторгнення в Україну
інформаційна війна за їхніми словами
розгорнулася на повну
музичний кліп депутата держдуми Дениса
Майданова на російському державному
телебаченні прославляє міті ракети
Сармат здатної доставити ядерні
боєголовки аж до США
ким ти прийняте рішення
Володимир Путін спрямує погрозою
застосувати ці ракети
так для людства це буде глобальна
катастрофа для світу це буде глобальною
катастрофою але навіщо нам Такий світ
якщо там не буде Росії
демонстрація російської сили спрямована
на НАТО на сході Латвії є багато людей
які відчувають тісний зв'язок з Росією
каже Марія дубіцька
[музика]
вона налаштована інакше як латвійка Вона
пишається тим що її Країна тепер Член ЄС
а не Радянського Союзу вона розповідає
що її батька колись депортували до
Сибіру війна в Україні пробуджує темні
спогади
повна частина людей тут чекають війни це
якийсь повний абсурд є думки що
повернеться колишня радянська влада у
тому сенсі якою вона була раніше
І тепер вони хочуть щоб Росія теж сюди
прийшла і ось ця політика досі
транслюється транслюється у голови людей
[музика]
така Радянська анастагічна фантазія
відроджується орезик на особливо серед
людей які почуваються покинутими через
ризик не проходить шосе що з'єднує Ригу
і Москву майже половина мешканців міста
російськомовні і багато з них знаходять
способи дивитися заборонене російське
державне телебачення хоче з початком
війни мало хто в цьому зізнається вас
задовольняють російські медіа
задовольняють А як щодо якості пробачте
я поспішаю у нас зараз такі часи що
краще не відповідати
люди бояться озвучити свою думку
є такі хто плює в екран піною Я завжди
дивилася Балтійське телебачення багато
пропаганди і звідти і звідти
експерти стверджують що російська
пропаганда намагається вплинути на
велику російську меншину в Латвії
розколоти суспільство але це також може
бути надмірним узагальненням
до населення влади неоднорідне
є люди які вперті не хочуть вчити мову і
мають більш про кремлівські погляди
А є ціле покоління яке народилося і
виросло за часів незалежності і вони
доволі лояльні і мислять по європейські
хоч звісно використовують російську мову
у побуті
Латвія в особливо вразливому становищі
на зовнішньому кордоні НАТО ще один
аспект який Пропаганда не залишає без
уваги
як на прикладу ток-шоу на російському
державному телебаченні колишній
військовий офіцер розповідає як Росія
могла б крок за кроком вторгнутися в
Латвію та інші дві балтійські республіки
угрупової російської армії збройні сили
Білорусії перекривають всю валківський
коридор
а водночас із території західно-воєного
округу контингенти входять до Естонії до
Латвії до Литви
оголошують створення Естонської народної
республіки
Латвійська Народна Республіка і
литовської народної республіки все
такі розмови розраховані на те що
посіяти страх але Марію дубітько не
залякати і Вона вимагає від держави
докласти більше зусиль щоб зупинити
російську пропаганду
Ми хочемо жити вільно на землі Ми не
хочемо бути під чиєюсь владою і тут ми
все ж маємо право самостійно вирішувати
Як нам жити Що нам робити І це дуже
важливо
Марія дубіцька сподівається що більше не
буде втрачати друзів і знайомих
вона насолоджується вільним часом у селі
далеко від Російської пропаганди
А тепер Дозвольте мені представити вам
жінку яка викликає захоплення філомену
Франц У 1943 році її відправили до
нацистського концтабору свенсон більші
членів її сім'ї загинули у концтаборі
але Філомена Франц зуміла врятуватись
від газових камер вона набралася
сміливості і заспівала перед своїми
котами усього кілька тижнів тому
Філомена Франц зробила свій останній
подих у віці 100 років
концентраційний табір Освенцим між 1940
і 1945 роками нацисти вбили тут Понад
мільйон людей Більшість із них були
євреями але також серед них були багато
ромів та сімті як Філомена Франції яка
до своєї нещодавньої смерті продовжувала
ділитися спогадами про тортури і
приниження свідком яких вона стала в
освенцімі
знаєте це було нелюдською жорстокістю
нас тримали в бараках внизу Крематорій
де спалювали людей був над нами
а наш Барак прямо під ним Там отримували
і мене але якось так сталося що мій час
тоді ще на закінчився
майже вся Її родина була вбита нацистами
самій філомені Франц був лише 21 рік
коли її відправили в освенцім
там вона на собі відчула безглузді
расистські практики нацистів
вони розпочали з того що виміряли мій
ніс Мої вуха все виміряли
я це був суцільний расизм
ніщо інше для них не мало значення
Вони хотіли знати походження сінці і
таке інше
але Філомена Франц виросла у штутгарті
вона походила з відомої родини
музикантів які жили в Німеччині протягом
століть як і багато інших сінті
Ми займалися музикою
ми заробляли гроші чесним шляхом і у нас
був чудовий будинок у штутгарті
Коли я була дівчинкою 12 чи 13 років я
вже співала на сцені під акомпанемент
оркестру
я співала цю пісню
[музика]
саме ця пісня врятує її життя коли до
освенцима приїде Генрі гімлер
сумнозвісний начальник СС хотів щоб
в'язні виконали для нього свою музику і
Вони знали що це може означати
[музика]
це був наш останній шанс не піти через
той димар
І вони сказали Нам Якщо ці з вас хто
вміє грати не задовольняти його зараз то
Нам усім кінець
і яка я вдячна Я знала цю пісню
бо я завжди співала найновіша мелодія
навіть удома
потім начальник табору наказав
відімкнути бараки де зберігалися
інструменти в'язнів
вони принесли всі інструменти і в мене
був цілий оркестр
все чудове
ми репетирували цілих три дні
І нарешті я заспівала пісню
яку він забажав
із оркестром Це було чудово У мене були
Сльози на очах оркестр був божественний
минуле роки перш ніж Філомена Франц
змогла розповісти про всю ту жневагою
муки які вона пережила за цей час але
врешті-решт бажання висловитися і
розповісти світові про пережити
взялогору
вона почала писати і публічно виступати
як очевидець у засобах масової
інформації у школах та інших закладах
Вона розповідала про звірства які чинили
нацисти
[музика]
я роками думала про те що могло
спонукати людей кидати дітей у
кремаційну піч на очах у їхніх матерів
чинити такі нелюдські злочини
вона отримала багато нагород в тому
числі німецький хрест за заслуги і
ніколи не припиняла звертатися до молоді
знаєте коли я розповідала свою історію
читала лекції студенти плакали
Більше всього на світі мені хотілося
відвідувати школи я подумала треба
починати з молодого покоління
Старі вже налаштовані по-своєму є вже не
змінити
а з молодих ще можна щось зробити
Добро переможе Філомена Франц була
переконана у цьому до самого кінця вона
знаходила силу у християнській Вірі і
незважаючи на всі свої страждання вона
не залишила у своєму серці місця для
ненависті коли ти пройшов через щось
подібне через Освенцим через стій великі
табори то кажеш собі Чому я маю
ненавидіти відео це повинна я
продовжувати робити те що робили інші
чи повинна я їх ненавидіти ненависть це
не варіант
якщо мене наведемо ми програємо
любов це благословення для нас людей
якщо ми не маємо любові ми відмовляємось
від нашого духу і нашої гідності і тоді
втрачаємо в себе
потужне послання від неймовірної жінки
100 років філомени Франц
[музика]
важливі слова які ми всі повинні
пам'ятати Ідемо далі Коли ви думаєте про
Францію ви неодмінно згадуєте її кафе та
бістро зрештою це візитна картка
французького способу життя для багатьох
французів бістро це практично друга
вітальня чи дім поза домом
Чи краще сказати Вони були такими
кількість бістро у Франції невпинно
зменшується
Разом із ними зникають частина
французької культури
одна асоціація в Парижі бореться за те
щоб зберегти культуру бістро її члени
вважають бістро важливим культурним
надбанням яке слід зберегти
[музика]
на світанку в Парижі перші ознаки життя
з'являються у бістро
колись вони були візитівкою Парижа але
сьогодні стають дедалі більш рідкісним
явищем
Ален фонтен керує своїм бістров вже
понад 20 років а зараз очолює асоціацію
яка хоче добитися захисту Юнеско для
таких закладів як його
культура бістро - це місце де можна
говорити про все що завгодно як про
важливе так і про щось тривіальне
але для цього має бути відповідна
атмосфера і бістро не може бути надто
охайним мої бістро має душу тут багато
речей які належали моїй родині наприклад
шолом мого батька і старій сімейні
фотографії
але незалежно від темного розмов сім'я
кохання чи політика для багатьох бістро
на розі це як другий дім відкритий З
раннього ранку до пізньої ночі
Я завжди спілкуюсь тут з усіма це чудове
місце для зустрічей із людьми
бістро розшифровується як радість життя
це місце де можна розслабитися і просто
радіти життю
і смачно поїсти наприклад стейк тартар у
будь-який час доби
[музика]
але зовні світ кардинально змінився 40
років тому у Франції було у 5 разів
більше бістро ніж сьогодні
власники сподіваються що якщо Юнеско
надасть маленьким бістро статус Світової
спадщини це може змінити ситуацію і хоча
це не принесе власникам ніяких прямих
грошей але бістро як об'єкт Світової
спадщини без сумнівно стане хорошою
рекламою
[музика]
реклама про яку мережу фаст-фудів можуть
лише мріяти
старовинне місто Париж надзвичайно
популярне і великі компанії витісняють з
ринку все більше і більше й бістро
інфлендсерів таких як флорін он Ейр
приваблює зовсім інший тип ресторанів
він постійно досліджує місто У пошуках
найновіших кулінарних трендів щоб
показати їх своїм підписникам ви
збільшуємо вірністю знайдете
креативність і нові концепції деінде але
нефтивковому французькому пісок сьогодні
блог Флоріана привів його до
першокласного тайського ресторану
вуличної їжі але вся його любов до
нового не заважає його бажанню зберегти
старе бістро
Я люблю бістрований дуже типові для
Франції
багет вже в списку Юнеско то чому б не
включити бістро
інфлює підтримують ідею але Міністерство
культури вагається
а саме звідти має надійти офіційна заява
до Юнеско власник бістрофонтен
обурюється відсутністю інтересу
чиновників до їхніх зусиль
вже вже двічі відмовляли Чому Тому що ми
не вписуємося усі рамки конвенції ЮНЕСКО
ця конвенція не дає мені спати ночами
проблема власникам важко визначити що
таке бістро адже кожна із них унікальне
якими б індивідуальними вони не були і
їх об'єднує одне відчуття шарму і
традицій
Ален фонтен впевнений що бістро
отримують визнання на яке вони
заслуговують тому що і парижани і
туристи вже давно зрозуміли Франція не є
Францією без своїх бістро
у Європі ціни зросли через інфляцію
особливо в Польщі у деяких регіонах ціни
на продукти харчування зросли вдвічі
ціни на електроенергію та газ також з
рослин найбільше страждають пенсіонери
коли Галина йде за покупками їй
доводиться задовольнятися найменшим у
всьому що вона не може собі дозволити їй
доводиться покладатися на соціальній
універмаг навіть у тій Відчайдушні часи
Галина впевнена що Ніколи б не стала
красти але багато власників магазинів у
Польщі скаржаться на збільшення
кількості крадіжок оскільки навіть
основні продукти харчування схоже стали
недоступними для багатьох Шимон шивона
вішає на холодильнику своєму магазині
табличку увага масло у холодильнику біля
каси Чому Тому що тут у дальньому кутку
його крамниці у кельці воно більше не в
безпеці
Ми помітили що з холодильника зникло
близько 30% масла
[музика]
перевіривши записи з камер спостереження
та інвентаризацію Ми вирішили продавати
масло на касі ціна на вершкове масло у
Польщі зросла майже на 50%. рекордна
інфляція призвела до того що ціни на
цілу низку продуктів харчування та
напоїв злетіли до небес особливо сильно
постраждали люди похилого віку пенсії
яких не вистачає Шимон помітив що саме
ці люди частіше крадуть у його крамниці
коли ціни подвоюються чи навіть
потроюються а пенсії залишаються такими
ж як і півроку тому Ну що ж їм
доводиться вигадувати нові способи щоб
звести кінці з кінцями
згідно з останніми статистичними даними
кількість крадіжок у Польщі зросла майже
на третину
і знову і знову винуватцями стають
пенсіонери
пенсіонери такі як Галина з Варшави вона
каже що ніколи нічого не крала хоча її
пенсії вже давно не вистачає навіть не
те щоб нормально наповнити холодильник
продуктами
[музика]
після сплати орендної плати та рахунків
у Галини залишається близько 100 євро на
місяць на життя незважаючи на те що вона
отримує державну пенсію
цей магазин дійсно чудовий
усе стало таким дорогим
від молочних продуктів до фруктів і
овочів
а тут ціни більш доступні для таких
пенсіонерів як я
магазин працює на пожертви і останніми
місяцями сюди приходить все більше і
більше людей особливо хворих і літніх
яким ледве вистачає коштів на оренду
житла та медичні витрати
дуже багато людей приходять і дякують
нам кажуть що якби не ми їм довелося б
голодувати останній тиждень місяця тому
що у них просто немає грошей
інфляція що становить майже 16% і
продовжує зростати призводить до
зниження якості їхнього життя особливо
страждають люди похилого віку з пенсіями
які лише трохи перевищують поріг
соціальних виплат оскільки вони не
отримують жодної подальшої підтримки
Галина відвідує місцевий супермаркет де
її покупці і продавці відчувають вплив
стрімкої інфляції дрібні крадіжки стали
частиною повсякденного життя
Так ми бачимо це все частіше і частіше
люди можуть поцупити помідор яблуко
раніше такого не було
Галина тепер рідко купує на ринках бо це
занадто дорого але вона заходить до
кіоску до сита що у перекладі означає
ситий
кіоск вжегожа є джейчука працює за
принципом щедрості кожен хто купує тут
їжу може пожертвувати другу порцію для
людей у яких зараз складні часи
кожен хто хоче їсти може прийти до нас і
отримати їжу
якщо комусь це не дуже потрібно то не
варто приходити
Галина приходить до кіоску жегоза щодня
Раніше вона взагалі не обідила Іноді він
навіть дає їй свіжу м'ясну нарізку яку
купує для неї
дуже дуже вам дякую
Від щирого серця вам дякую
дорогі мої я бажаю вам міцного здоров'я
ви були поруч зі мною І я дуже вдячна за
це дякую вам
Галина живе нелегким життям Але завдяки
таким людям як жегош вона теж може
відчувати турботу у ці важкі часи
для таких українців як Ольга Осадча є
унікальний скарбу швейцарському
базельському художньому музеї 100 картин
відомих українських художників усього
через кілька тижнів після початку війни
в Україні ці твори мистецтва були
вивезені з Києва та перевезення у
безпечне місце саме напередодні того як
російська ракета влучили у національну
галерею деякі з цих картин зараз
виставлені на загальний огляд на
виставці народження в Україні
це були б чудові новини Чи не так що ви
думаєте про це ви можете зв'язатися з
нами у Твіттері Ви також можете
подивитися шоу на нашому сайті І
поділитися ними з друзями та родиною А
на сьогодні це все дякуємо що були з
нами Побачимось наступного тижня
залишайтеся здоровими і до зустрічі
українською мовою озвучено центром медіа
ініціатив Київ 2023 рік
[музика]